L Le panel politique ce soir ac
JoJosée Legault, Michel C. Auger
etet Alec Castonguay. Bonsoir.
JeJe prends l'exemple de la
scscientifique en chef du Canada
ququi dit qu'il faut revoir
cecertaine façon qu'on a, entre
auautres les tests dans les
aéaéroports... on peut se demanr
sisi le coût t bénéfice ne devit
papas déséquilibré. Est-ce que e
n'n'est pas un exemple où il fat
dedes fois revoir le bien parce
quque le bien peut devenir
exexagéré?
- - C'est difficile de se
prprononcer sur cette question
paparce que ça soulèveve beaucoe
popossibilités. Je serais bien à
l'l'aise d'avoir un immunologue
àà c côtété de moi. Si on avaits
tetests de dépistage qui nous
lelevait dessus, s'il n'y avait
papas de contagion comommunauta,
nonous avons une pénurie de tous
ceces choses et nous avons une
cocommunauté importante. Est-ce
ququ'on doit investir autant de
reressources à l l'aéroport? La
ququestion se pose. Je n'ai pasa
réréponse.
- - Une fois qu'il est entré et
ququ'il se propage partout dansa
cocommunauté. Qu'est-ce que ça
vovous inspire?
- - Je ne suis pas partisan de
lalaisser tomber les mesures
sasanitaires à c ce moment, mail
nene faut pas faire double empli
nonon plus. Pour entrer dans
l'l'avion, il faut donner une
prpreuve de test négatif. C'est
ququand mêmeme assez rare que çe
dédéveloppe avec trois heures
d'd'avion au moment où on desce.
IlIl y a des choses qui ne sont
papas utiles. En plus de dire
enencore une fois, il y a de la
trtransmission communautaire ic.
CeCe n'es pas très s utile.
- - Il y a beaucoup d'incohérens
àà l la frontièrere. On ne tests
cece qui arrive en avion des
EÉtats-Unis, alors qu'Omicron, n
dedes endroits où il se propagee
plplus et aux États-Unis.
CoComme dit Michel, en embarquat
dadans l'avion on se tests, et n
dodoit retester en sortant. Il a
1 1 % des tests à l la frontièri
sosont revenus positifs. Des ges
prprobablement trèss
asasymptomatiques parce qu'ils
sosont doublement vaccinés. Este
quque pour 1 % de gens qui
ararrivent ici dans une
trtransmission communautaire déà
trtrès s forte, est-ce que ça vt
unun demi milliard? Les retards
popour les gens qui doivent
atattendre le résultat de leurs
tetests à l la maison c cette ae
jojour... c'est plus que le cinq
jojours qu'on a maintenant dansa
plplupart des provinces. Il y a
bebeaucoup de politiques autoure
lala frontièrere et ça commenceà
fafaire un peu bizarre que la
scscience soit à c ce point laie
dede côtété.
- - Ce qui m'amènene à u un aute
susujet : le questionnement que
leles gens ont au Québec quand l
vovoit les mesures... Michel, vs
avavez dit que vous ne croyez ps
quque c'est le moment d'assouplr
leles règlgles. Or, je vous mone
un p petit tableau. Aujourd'hui,
c'c'est les soins intensifs qui
esest devenu le marqueur par
exexcellence. Au Québec 33 par
mimillions d'habitants, plus que
lala moyenne canadienne.
MoMonsieur Legault hier à t twir
ququ'il y en a moins qu'en
OnOntario. Ma question : est-ce
quque les gens ne sont pas en
drdroit de se dire comment ça se
fafait qu'on a depuis le début s
memesures les plus strictes et e
leles résultats soient soient
cocomparables ou plus mauvais
ququ'ailleurs?
- - C'est un questionnement
lélégitime. Mais en mêmeme tempn
pepeut comprendre sur le couvre-
fefeu, parce que le retour du
cocouvre-feu avant le jour de ln
ététait incompréhensible. S'il
avavait été si efficace, ça aurt
eueu lieu dans le reste du Canaa
etet le premier ministre n'aurat
papas annoncé qu'il l'annulait à
papartir de ce soir.
PoPour le reste, je suis d'accod
avavec Michel. On est encore das
lele principe de précaution. De
ququelles mesures parle-t-on? Le
poport du masque, de nombreux
ététats, les spécialistes
rerecommandent mêmeme de porters
mamasques N95. Pas ce qu'utilist
leles chirurgiens, mais des
mamasques plus efficaces que les
mamasques médicaux disponibles n
vevente libre. Est-ce qu'on pare
dede la ventilation, dont on ne
s's'occupe pas beaucoup au Québc
paparce que le gouvernement hése
àà r reconnaîtrtre que la
trtransmission se fait par
aéaérosols. Je pense qu'on devrt
mmêmeme accentuer ces mesures.
- - On est en droit de se poser
dedes questions. Quelle est la
vavariable qui n'est pas la même
dadans toutes les provinces
cacanadiennes, c'est l'état du
sysystèmeme de santé en parce
paparticulier. Quand on entend
MoMonsieur Dubé dire que 50 000
pepersonnes manquent dans le
sysystèmeme de santé, il y en a
d'd'autres qui disent 70 000.
NoNotre collègugue de la gazetti
fafait souvent des longues séris
dede tweets les fins de semaine
didisaient de parler aux gens ds
leles hôpipitaux. Si une infirme
esest responsable de deux fois
plplus de patients et qu'il y a
unune urgence quelque part, elle
n'n'aura pas le temps de s'occur
d'd'une deuxièmeme urgence. Peu-
êêtrtre que la réponse, pourquoi
l'l'Ontario va mieux que le Quéc
etet tout ça, c'est le fait quee
sysystèmeme est vraiment sur le
popoint de rupture depuis le dét
dede cette phase.
- - Je ne sais pas si
acactuellement, l'Ontario va mix
TéTélé-Québec. Il y a moins de
momorts. Vous ouvrait un autre
dédébat. On les calcule
didifféremment. On aura la répoe
dadans six mois.
- - Je n'y crois pas. À la fin,n
momort et un mort.
- - Rapidement, c'est aussi làùu
onon a moins bien fait ici, c'et
lala question de la ventilation
dadans les écoles. En Ontario, n
a a été beaucoup plus proactif.
PoPour les masques N95, on est
plplus proactif dans d'autres
prprovinces. Le premier ministre
didit aux Québécois que ce n'est
papas plus efficace que les
mamasques médicaux, alors que ls
exexperts disent le contraire.
- - Je vais ouvrir toute sorte e
paparenthèsese. Sur les masques,
ININSPQ a dit que le masque de
prprocédure était aussi efficace
quque le N95 dans une classe.
- - Je ne parle pas au nom des
exexperts qui sont indépendantsu
gogouvernement, mais regardez
totoutes les études scientifiqus
ququi sortent depuis quelques
sesemaines, à t travers le mond,
totout ce monde dit le contrair.
- - Alec, je ne vous ai pas
ououblié. Le sujet de discussio,
c'c'est est-ce que malgré nos
memesures plus strictes
ququ'ailleurs, passeport vaccinl
popour entrer dans les grandes
susurfaces, etc., on ne voit pas
nénécessairement les bénéfices e
sasa.
- - Ça dépend avec qui vous
cocomparez. Par rapport à
l'l'Ontario qui a à p peu près s
mmêmemes mesures que nous
mamaintenant que le couvre-feu t
enenlevé, en Ontario, les salles
etet les restaurants sont fermé.
AuAu Canada, il y a la Colombie-
BrBritannique où il y a des
rerestaurants ouverts. Aux État-
UnUnis, c'est une autre mentali.
EtEt en Europe, on a géré ça un
pepeu différemment. Je pense qun
vovoudrait bien apprendre à v ve
avavec le véreux au Québec si
nonotre systèmeme de santé n'étt
papas aussi fragile. Mais tant
ququ'on est encore à p plus de 0
hohospitalisations... On a ouvet
leles écoles et enlever le couv-
fefeu, je pense qu'on ne peut ps
alaller plus loin d'ici deux ou
trtrois semaines avant de voir
ceceux à q quoi va ressembler
l'l'épidémiologie. Et on peut
dodonner un peu plus d'oxygènene
paparce qu'il faut que ça baise
dadans les hôpipitaux. On ne pet
papas rester à u un niveau de
dédélestage comme celui-là..
- - Très s bien. Combien il nous
rereste de temps? Marguerite
BlBlais, un petit mot là-d-dess.
C'C'était vendredi. José, vous
avavez écouté les témoignages
dedevant la coronaire. Je vous
fafais entendre un petit extrai.
MAMARGUERITE BLAIS, min. Aînénés
etet Proches aidants, Québec
- - L'enquêtete de la coroner,
c'c'est une enquêtete important.
JeJe veux remercier Madame
lala coroner Kamel parce qu'avec
soson enquêtete, qui est finalet
pupublique, ça va faire en sorte
ququ'on va changer la façon dont
onon prend soin de nos personnes
ââgégées.
- - Je vous rappelle qu'elle est
enen congé de maladie, qui est n
rerepos et est venu témoigner
dedevant la coronaire. Qu'est-ce
quque vous avez retenu? La
mamanchette a été : encore
ququelques contradictions entre
leles ministres sur le moment ùu
onon est intervenue en CHSLD.
- - J'ai trouvé ça un peu bizare
ququ'on titre ça. Lorsqu'on pare
dede la ministre de la santé
DaDaniel McCann et Horacio Arrua
ququi ont affirmé devant la
cocoronaire qu'ils avaient averi
leles PDG Plesius de préparer ls
CHCHSLD. Or, tout ce qui a été
sosoumis présentement, y compris
cece qu'a dit la ministre, c'est
exexactement le contraire. C'est
unune contradiction face a une
veversion qui n'était pas
crcrédible, qui avait été dénoné
papar tous. J'ai trouvé la
miministre solide. Ce qu'elle a
didit en sortant est trèss
imimportant parce que ça reflète
auaussi ce que la coronaire luia
didit en toute fin d'audience.
C'C'est que son travail à e ell,
GéGéhane Kamel, c'était de trour
cece qui s'était passé pour
amaméliorer les choses à l l'av.
EtEt Madame Blais a dit quelque
chchose de très s important. Ela
didit qu'il le faudra pour que e
pepeuple invisible, c'est commea
ququ'elle appelle toutes les
pepersonnes vulnérables au Québ,
popour que ce peuple invisible
dedevient peut-êtrtre celui qu'n
jojour on aimera le plus.
C'C'est très s important. J'ai
trtrouvé la chimie entre la
cocoronaire et la ministre, il y
avavait une bonne chimie. On
vovoyait que la coroner Kamel
avavait beaucoup de respect pour
lala ministre Blais. Est la
reremercié à l la fin, il lui a
dedemandé de conserver ses vales
huhumaines. Elle n'a pas dit çaà
totout le monde. On a vu
ququ'aujourd'hui, ça a été le
cocontraire. Elle était vraiment
exexaspérée parce qu'elle n'est
papas capable d'avoir des versis
crcrédibles. Mais je pense que
vevendredi, elle a eu une versin
crcrédible.
- - Marguerite Blais a confirmée
ququ'on savait déjà, , parce qua
prprotectrice du citoyen avait
fafait déjà e enquêtete. J'avais
épépluché tous les procès-s-verx
dedes rencontres du ministèreree
lala santé en janvier et févrie,
etet jamais il n'avait été mentn
dedes CHSLD. Beaucoup de témoins
onont dit que ce n'était pas sur
leles écrans radar du ministre.a
seseule personne qui a été trop
loloin dans son témoignage, ses
DaDaniel Megan qui a dit qu'ella
enenvoyé une note aux CHSLD.
OnOn ne peut pas se baser là--
dedessus. C'est du révisionnisme
hihistorique. Marguerite Blais a
coconfirmé ce qu'on savait déjàt
cece que le gouvernement a lui-
mmêmeme admis en disant qu'ils e
sosont pris trop tard. Je ne
cocomprends pas pourquoi la
veversion de Mme McCann circule
enencore. Peut-êtrtre qu'on avat
didit ça vaguement, mais beaucop
trtrop vaguement pour les CHSLD.
- - Je vous relance, Paul St-
PiPierre Plamondon dans Bourget
susur l'îlele de Montréal, est-e
quque c'est un choix intéressan?
- - C'est un choix intéressant.
C'C'est un compte historique por
lele PQ, qui va s'applique
amaméliorer lorsque l'élection
sesera déclenchée. C'est une lue
àà t trois entre le député sortt
dede la CAQ, le PQ et Québec
sosolidaire. Dans une lutte à
DaDans une lutte à 3 3,1 che
avavantagé, il a beaucoup plus e
vivisibilité que les autres. Et
BoBourget, c'est Montréal.
C'C'est plus facile d'aller donr
unune entrevue que quand on estn
trtrain de descendre d'une toure
auau lac Saint-Jean.
- - Je suis d'accord avec Miche.
C'C'est sûr r que pour le Parti
ququébécois et son chef, il n'a
plplus de forteresse à p part
MaMatane. Il doit risquer quelqe
chchose, et à r risquer, c'est -
êêtrtre son meilleur pari. C'est
pepeut-êtrtre le moins pire de s
leles autres.
- - Ça fera oublier Marie
ViVictorin. Marie Victorin, Anne
CaCasabonne, Éric Duhaime est aé
chchercher cette comédienne qu'n
coconnaît t très s bien, qui avt
trtraité les vaccins comme étant
dede la m... puis a dit qu'elle
fafaisait de l'ironie. Est Éric
DuDuhaime a fait politiquement n
bobon coup?
- - C'est un coup de publicité
paparce qu'on a parti de son pai
totoute la journée. Est-ce qu'ee
a a de véritables chances de
reremporter, la réponse est non.
J'J'espèrere qu'elle s'est.
C'C'est une circonscription où l
y y a déjà d des candidats
inintéressants et importants qui
vovont se présenter. Ses chances
sosont faibles. Mais c'est certn
quque ça fait parti de la
ststratégie de communication
d'd'attirer l'attention.
IlIl faudra aussi faire un peu
atattention parce qu'on se colle
tetellement aux anti mesures
sasanitaires, aux anti vaccin, e
ceceux qui croient à l la pandée
etet qui pense qu'on a un rôlele
cocollectif à j jouer et qui soe
drdroite économique, qui auraitu
êêtrtre intéressé par Éric Duhae
inintéressé par Éric Duhaime, ac
ququels types de personnnnes vot
ilils vont s'acoquiner s'ils
vovotent pour ce pa
- - C'est exactement ça le
prproblèmeme. Monsieur Duhaime t
dedevenu le porte-parole des ani
vavaccins. Rendu au mois
d'd'octobre, peut-êtrtre que cee
sesera plus à l la question quia
lului êtrtre rentable. On oublie
pependant ce temps-là d droite
écéconomique qui se cherche une
plplace.
- - Je pense qu'il cherche surtt
àà f fédérer les gens qui sont n
cocolèrere contre le gouvernemet
LeLegault. Une partie de la
popopulation très s minoritairei
vovoit François Legault comme un
dadangereux socialiste dictateur
ququi va contrôleler la vie des
QuQuébécois.
- - On ne connaît t pas encore a
dadate, mais quelque part au
prprintemps il y aura cette
papartielle dans Marie Victorin.
OnOn n'y r